das Eigenheim im Grünen das wollen die
meisten Deutschen doch es gibt ein
Problem ein Familienhäuser gelten als
Klimakiller und beanspruchen viel Fläche
zu viel Fläche eines natürlich immer
mehr eine Verschwendung dass relativ
dünn und mit Einfamilienhäusern zu bauen
immer mehr Städte und Regionen wollen
den Bau von Einfamilienhäusern nun
beschränken und zur Ausnahme machen wir
befinden uns im Klimawandel wir können
die Fläche nicht mehr in dieser
Sorglosigkeit versiegeln aus der Traum
vom eigenen Haus kommt das
flächendeckende hausbauverbot und was
sind die Alternativen
es ist eine Siedlung wie sie an den
meisten Rändern unserer Dörfer und
Städte in Deutschland zu finden ist ein
Familienhäuser Wand an Wand in monotona
funktionaler Einförmigkeit
Autogarage an der Seite Satteldach der
Boden größtenteils versiegelt
das wenige Grün das hier noch geduldet
ist eingezwängt zwischen Kies und Beton
ein Wohnmodell das in Münster künftig so
nicht mehr in der Fläche vorgesehen ist
freistehende Einfamilienhäuser sollen
hier zur Ausnahme werden es ist so dass
wir im Sinne der klimagerechten
Bauleitplanung dichtekonzepte verfolgen
die natürlich in unterschiedlichen
gebäudedichten und Mischungen einen
Fokus legen auf Mehrfamilienhäuser das
Einfamilienhaus ein Klimakiller Tatsache
ist der Traum von den eigenen vier
Wänden ist aus Klimaschutzgründen kaum
noch zu vertreten der Energie und
Wärmeverlust bei freistehenden Häusern
mit Abstand am größten denn jeder
bewohnte Quadratmeter muss beleuchtet
und beheizt werden auch der
Flächenverbrauch ist enorm während auf
einem Hektar Baufläche 25 freistehende
Einfamilienhäuser Platz finden sind es
bei Reihenhäusern bereits doppelt so
viele Wohneinheiten
rund 56 Hektar werden in Deutschland
laut Umweltbundesamt pro Tag für
siedlungs- und Verkehrsflächen
ausgewiesen eine Größe von etwa 79
Fußballfeldern
wenn ich einfamilienhausgebiete
erschließen will dann heißt dass ich
Baustraßen ich baue Wasserleitungen ich
baue Strom und sonstige
erschließungsmedien und vor allen Dingen
brauche ich Infrastruktur und deswegen
brauche ich andere dichte andere
Kompaktheit aber mit Qualität versehen
nicht einfach nur zu bauen doch der
Wunsch nach dem Einfamilienhaus ist seit
Jahrzehnten ungebrochen für zwei Drittel
aller Deutschen ist es der Wohntraum
jedes Jahr kommen rund 100.000 neue
Einfamilienhäuser hinzu
Anfänge dieses Booms gehen zurück in die
50er Jahre und waren teils politisch
motiviert Adenauer hat in den frühen
50er Jahren das Eigenheim
als bewusst
antikommunistische Entwicklung
verstanden also man wollte die Leute
fördern in das Eigenheim zu gehen gerade
die es sich nicht leisten können damit
die nicht so anfällig werden für
kommunistische Ideologien mit massiver
staatlicher Förderung wurden Millionen
von Bausparverträgen und das Volk
gebracht mit ihrer Hilfe werden jetzt
immer mehr fertige Eigentumswohnungen
und Eigenheime den Bausparen Angeboten
Klimaschutz und Flächenverbrauch
spielten damals noch keine Rolle damals
war die genutzte Siedlungsfläche in
Deutschland eine sehr überschaubare es
gab wenig Autobahnen weniger Straßen es
gab Freiraum ohne Ende das war also in
dem Sinne kein Thema das eigene Heim in
der Neubausiedlung am Stadtrand es war
nicht nur das große Lebensglück
versprechen es bediente gleichsam auch
das Bild der traditionellen Familie die
Frau die zu Hause das Haus und die
Kinder besorgt der bitte in die Stadt
rein pendelt und dort arbeitet all das
schwingt dann mit und wurde zu so einem
Art zu so einer Art Lebensmodell und
insofern
kann man in Studien eben sehr stark mit
dem Einzug ins Einfamilienhaus auch in
späteren Generationen eine
retraditionalisierung feststellen fast
jeder sechste Deutsche hatte Mitte der
70er Jahre einen Bausparvertrag das
eigene Haus ein Statussymbol mit allem
was im Wirtschaftswunderland noch dazu
gehörte
sie konsumieren auf das Haus
ausgerichtet sprich sie kaufen nicht nur
eben dann entsprechend den PKW und im
pendeln zu können sondern sie kaufen
auch entsprechend alle möglichen
Angebote die im Baumarkt Märkten
angeboten werden oder im Garten merken
die weitere Elektrifizierung des
Haushalts mit Kühlschränken
Waschmaschine und so weiter und das ist
eben auch für die
sich entwickelnde Wohlstandsgesellschaft
ganz wichtig 50 Jahre später hat sich
vieles verändert es gibt
Patchworkfamilien Baugrund ist kostbar
Klima und Umweltschutz wichtig eine
Entwicklung der diese modellsiedlungen
in Münster Rechnung tragen soll
das ist ein Beitrag zur flächensparsam
in Anspruchnahme von Ressourcen so eben
auch Grund und Boden und je weiter man
in den Außenbereich geht desto weniger
dicht ist die Bebauung in der Regel
desto mehr Verkehr erzeugt man und das
ist genau die Gegenposition die wir hier
in Münster aufbauen können Vater
verantwortungsvoll aber eben auch dicht
und vor allem zentrumsnah mit Wohnraum
umzugehen nicht nur in Münster auch in
vielen anderen Städten dürfte das
Einfamilienhaus immer mehr zum
Auslaufmodell werden ein Lösungsansatz
bauverdichtung ein anderer bereits
vorhandene Wohnsiedlungen an die
aktuellen Lebensbedürfnisse anzupassen
und umzubauen
dort muss die Musik spielen wie baue ich
diese Bestände um wie mache ich sie
zukunftsfit wie schaffe ich es dass der
Generationenwechsel funktioniert was
kann ich dazu bauen ohne den Charakter
der Siedlung jetzt vielleicht
grundlegend zu verändern den ja viele
mögen und das eher als bestandsthema zu
sehen und nicht immer ich will das neue
weiße Fertigteilhaus das ist eine
wichtige Zukunftsaufgabe trotz dieser
Forderung als Sehnsuchtsort wird das
Einfamilienhaus so schnell wohl nicht
aus den Köpfen der Menschen verschwinden